ich weiß noch heute das letzte mal
dieses spiel gespielt das war einer der
schlimmsten momente meines lebens aber
ich habe mir gedacht ich spiels nochmal
willkommen zu anfang mario was war das
lokal dabei geht es darum dass wir
diesen parcours hirscher ohne zu sterben
über also scheiß fallen versteckt das
heißt ich kann jetzt viel schauen und
irgendwann hier völlig herunter das
heißt die spring direkt auf den hier
raus jetzt geht's hier weiter
okay der nächste feld runter das heißt
wir gehen direkt hier auf warum ist ein
blog da kommt aber nicht drauf was
bringt der block mir irgendwas okay ich
taste mich ganz langsam vor ganz langsam
dieses spiel wird mich wieder an den
rand der verzweiflung befördern okay wir
sind hier das heißt ich springe hier
über das ziel dass ich es kann doch
nicht sein dass ich das die ganze zeit
nicht schaffen soll hier zurzeit hier
drüber da ist eine blöde ding
und jetzt
level komplett space for next level und
jedermann etwa das nächste level hier
bot okay luc bin ich dann voll du
kleines mistet gamezone jetzt hier
drüber das kann doch nicht wahr sein die
vorne waren auch staffeln kicker so
schön hier drüber geschlichen jetzt hier
nein ich da drauf ich wollte das vorland
von luca doch perfekt hier drunter her
hier drauf locker okay hier drunter her
alles klar ich wette ich muss ich muss
ich irgendwie drauf ja genau guckt jetzt
springe ich hier drüber jetzt hier
das kann doch nicht sein ich war so
unfassbar weit was soll ich noch in
meinem leben anfangen alter als lady auf
die andere plattformen und jetzt ganz
viel springt da ist doch gerade
irgendwelche schritte bei mir auf dem
flug gehört schauen wir immer ob ich
meine nachbarin davon tür spiel und
steht doch keiner habe ich mich nur
geträumt ist jetzt lass dir zeit locker
lass dir zeit hier drauf okay da jetzt
jetzt luca jetzt wohin vorhin ich
brauche eine neue taktik das kann so
nicht weitergehen ich kämpfe hier
treffen irgendwann nehme ich den apple
wie heißt der typ der diese scheiß
entwickelt hat sechseinhalb auslands
ruhig luca
das ist nicht schwer ich muss nur hier
kurz drauf auch okay erst einmal vorbei
das ist alles alles still ich bisher
alles gut alles gut alles gut
alles okay und jetzt die einmalige
chance das ist nicht möglich wenn ich es
irgendwie sehr gut luca okay okay der
amboss weg das heißt ich springe hier
ich kann ich nicht da oben drauf ich
kann irgend jemand von euch leute sehr
gut beruhigen weil ich glaube so was hab
ich jetzt nötig habe die absolute burner
taktik war erstmal den amboss hier
irgendwie lang
ganz ruhig luca ganz ruhig hierüber kurz
anlauf kommt ist doch nicht wahr sein
sonst schaffen dieser scheiß amboss kann
dies ja wahrscheinlich gibt sich
irgendeinen anderen verzichten weg an
diese bastarde vorbei zur ok ok und
jetzt hier runter und jetzt hier drüber
jumpen weiß genau welche drauf büro ist
ordnung okay wir wissen jetzt dass ich
über den amboss quasi drüber springen
kann dann kann ich hier runter gehen und
jetzt muss ich nur auf die erste ding
schöpfen jetzt auf die oberste und jetzt
hier den checkpoint erreichen die mit
den checkpoint gib mir doch okay ich hab
den checkpoint das heißt wenn ich jetzt
hier über ok wo man lang gesamte
natürlich direkt runter gefallen ok
meine lieben freunde jetzt die sind ganz
nah am ziel
ok jetzt